ja ich begrüße sie zur heutigen sitzung
in der wir uns mit kleinen beschäftigen
werden bevor wir aber auf klein näher
eingehen möchte ich noch ein rückblick
geben auf die letzte sitzung in der wir
uns befasst haben mit diesen herren ihr
einmal den jüngeren jahren einmal den
älteren jahren nämlich mit gottlob frege
was hat es mit diesem netten herrn mit
seinen mitteln fahrt auf sich hat ein
werk geschrieben unter anderem dialog
mit kuba über existenz das ist ein ganz
kleines ja kleiner dialog den er aus dem
gedächtnis heraus rekonstruiert hat und
da geht es eben um die frage was
existenz bedeutet grundsätzlich kann man
zufrieden sagen dass er der gründervater
der analytischen philosophie ist was ist
analytische philosophie analytische
philosophie versucht philosophische
probleme in erster linie durch logische
klärung der analyse der sprache bzw
unsere begriffe zu lösen also solche
philosophen die der analytischen schule
oder richtung zu gerechnet werden die
werden häufig logische methoden
verwenden um probleme zu lösen weiteren
bekannte analytische philosophen
nachfrage sind bertrand russell auf den
wirt wir heute ganz kurz eingehen
später dann ludwig wittgenstein und
verliert von klein auf denen wir eben in
der heutigen sitzung die dann das
nächste mal auf youtube gestellt wird
näher eingehen werden pflege hat eine
andere schrift verfasst die vielleicht
noch wichtiger ist als dieser dialog mit
können nämlich eine sogenannte begriffs
schrift und untertitel ist eine der
arithmetischen nachgebildete
formensprache des reinen denkens also es
geht ihm darum eine ideale sprache zu
entwickeln die unsere natürliche
sprachen unsere alltagssprache klärt und
verhindert dass aufgrund unserer
unpräzisen natürlichen sprache probleme
entstehen also das ist genau das
programm der analytischen philosophie
die halle sprache
eines denkens logisches denken und damit
unsere normale sprache reinigen auch
eine gewissen weise oder zumindest
kritisch analysieren
an dieser begriff schrift hat friege als
erster mit als erstes gab nach dem boule
dem kennen sie vielleicht die bullische
algebra aber somit als eine der ersten
logische notation eingeführt das hier
ist der inhalt strich ist einfach eine
position also das heute in münchen die
sonne scheint dass hier mit diesem
senkrechten strichen ist die behauptung
der position also die wahrheit der
position also nicht nur die behauptung
sind auch die der hat das der fall seine
position ist eine urteilt strich also
die proposition ist war in proposition
kann immer waren falsch sein dass hier
hingegen ist die verneinung der
proposition also heute schien in münchen
oder hand erscheint münchen nicht die
sonne das ist dann noch dieses
senkrechte striche in der modernen
notation wird es durch diesen haken hier
ausgedrückt dann gibt es jetzt so was
wie eine implikation also bnd danach die
implizierte sie müssen also von hier
nach dort gehen
und jetzt können sie sich überlegen was
das hier bedeutet na gut es muss
irgendwie ähnlich sein wie wir in
bedernau aber hier ist noch so ein
senkrechtes strichen und da sehen sie
hier das es die verneinung also wenn
nicht b danach so muss das ganze heißen
und diese rotation finden sie in dieser
begriff schrift von pflege zusammen mit
diesen mutationen also hier gibt es in
all quanto heute sieht er ebenso aus und
umgedrehtes frage hat das wie so eine
mulde gemacht und dann gibts auch den
existenz quanto den pflege eingeführt
hat der ergibt sich aus der doppelten
negation des alters also nicht für alles
gilt nicht fx heißt nicht für alle gilt
dass es nicht so ist dann muss es einige
geben oder zumindest einiges für das
gilt es ist es ist das prädikat so jetzt
hatten wir ein paar leitfragen worin
unterscheiden sich krieges und können
ihre auffassungen wie bestimmte regeln
existenz begriff wie verhält sich
weges existenz begriff zu demjenigen
kann wie verhält sich krieges existenz
begriff zu den wenigen meinung
das sind die fragen wollen jetzt sagt
dieser peña bernhard peña ein theologe
zu friedenszeiten seinem dialog es gibt
menschen heißt den begriff mensch
entspricht etwas erfahrbare oder etwas
von dem erfahrbaren fällt unter den
begriff mensch es gibt keine zentauren
heißt der vorstellung unter dem begriff
zehnter entspricht nichts erfahren
interessant ist jetzt hier das bin ja
ein bisschen im touristisch argumentiert
wir hatten gesagt es geht etwas in die
richtung von david hume auch wenn ja
natürlich jetzt kein klarer xmp er ist
ist aber erfahrbarkeit ist ja ein
ästhetisches prädikat jetzt kann man
sich fragen müssen mir wirklich etwas
erfahren können damit wir von ihm sagen
können das ist existierte das ist
existierten das ist die frage kriege
sagt dazu durch die aussage der
erfahrbarkeit wird das jährige von dem
sie ausgesagt wird nicht irgendwie
bestimmt also als erfahrbarkeit ist kein
unter logisches kriterium sind
systemisches prädikat weiter sagt können
ja einige menschen sind deutsche
bedeutet nicht dasselbe wie es gibt
deutschen menschen
sie dürfen aus dem satz sachse dessen
eigener achse ist ein mensch allein
nicht schließen es gibt menschen sollen
sie bedürfen dazu noch des satzes sachse
existiert ok also er sagt aus dem satz
sachse ist ein mensch folgt nicht es
gibt menschen sondern sachs existiert
muss noch als prämisse mit hinzugenommen
werden und zwar in der folgenden form
also sachse ist ein mensch saxe
existiert daraus folgt es gibt menschen
könnte man ja so denken wie gesagt jetzt
hingegen nein so dürfen wir existenz
nicht verstehen
er sagt folgendes hierauf würde ich
sagen wenn das hat sachsen existiert
heißen soll das wort sachse ist nicht an
lehrer schals und bezeichnet etwas so
ist es richtig dass die bedienung sachse
existiert erfüllt sein muss
dies ist aber keine neue prämie
es sei die selbstverständliche
voraussetzung bei allen unseren worten
die regeln der logik setzen immer voraus
dass die gebrauchten wollte nicht leer
sind dass die sätze ausdrücke von
urteilen sind dass man nicht mit bloßen
worten spiele sobald sachse ist ein
mensch ein wirkliches urteil ist muss
das wort sachse etwas bezeichnen und
dann brauche ich eine weitere prämisse
nicht um daraus zu schließen es gibt
menschen die prämisse sachse existiert
ist überflüssig wenn sie etwas anderes
bedeuten soll als jene
selbstverständliche voraussetzung der
allem unserem denken also die prämisse
die jetzt können ja hier gefordert hat
die sagt pflege brauchen wir nicht weil
wenn wir dann in sachsen existiert
verwenden wollen oder auch den das wort
sachse als sinnvolles wort als eigener
wenn es sinnvoll ist dann muss es schon
etwas geben was darunter fällt dann muss
es schon eine referenz haben ist
natürlich wieder interessant beiträge
die unterscheidung zwischen sinn und
bedeutung also bedeutung eines begriffs
eines wortes ist der gegenstand auf den
das wort referiert und sinn ist hingegen
der aspekt unter dem dieser gegenstand
uns erscheint aber das führt jetzt 2 das
ist ein weit anderes thema ja jetzt
geht's weiter frage sagt der satz einige
menschen existieren oder einiges
existierende ist mensch ist nur dann
gleichbedeutend mit es gibt menschen
wenn der begriff existieren dass die
begriffe mensch übergeordnet ist wenn
also jene ausdrucksweisen allgemein
gleichbedeutend sein sollen so muss der
begriff existierendes jedem begriffe
übergeordnet sein
dies ist nur dadurch möglich dass das
wort existieren etwas vollkommen
selbstverständlich es bedeutet das also
in dem satz leo sechs existiert gar
nichts ausgesagt werde
und das in dem satz einige menschen
existieren der inhalte aussage nicht in
dem worte existieren liege weiter sagt
frage die durch es gibt ausgedrückte
existenz kann nicht merkmal des begriffs
sein dessen eigenschaft ist eben weil
sie seine eigenschaft ist in dem satz es
gibt menschen scheint von individuum
gesprochen
die unter dem begriff mensch fallen
während doch nur vom begriffe mensch die
rede ist der inhalt des wortes
existieren kann nicht gut zum merkmal
eines begriffes genommen werden weil
existieren kein inhalt hat so wie es in
dem satz zu menschen existieren
gebraucht wird das erinnert natürlich
wieder an kantig nach oben rechts an dem
video einen link zur kant zu der
entsprechenden stelle hin wo kann sagte
existenz ist kein reales prädikat also
100 gedachte thale und 100 existierende
thaler sind real gleich viel
es sind nicht 101 thaler wenn 100
gedachte teile wirklich sind existenz
gehört nicht zum inhalt einer sache
sondern es betrifft nur den rahmen wie
ich es versucht hatte tat zu stellen
innerhalb dessen ein begriff thematisch
wird frage sollte dann davon sprechen
dass existenz ein begriff zweiter stufe
ist kein begriff erster stufe der
inhaltlich eine sache bestimmt
und jetzt will frege die these dass
existenz kein inhaltliches oder mit kant
reales prädikat ist weiter begründen und
er argumentiert in form einer reduktion
absurd
das ist also eine logische schluss form
die ich jetzt genau anhand seines stacks
es ihnen zeigen möchte
frege nimmt zunächst das gegenteil
seiner these an nämlich dass existenz
ein prädikat seiner sache sei das
existenz die sache inhaltlich bestimmt
er zeigt dann dass diese annahme keinen
widerspruch führt und folgert daraus
dass seine ursprüngliche these richtig
ist wenn es diese ausschließende
alternative von seiner these und der
anderen these gibt dieses argument sieht
jetzt also bezüglich der existenz
folgendermaßen aus entweder existenz ist
ein prädikat oder nicht das ist diese
ausschließen die alternative pflege will
dafür argumentieren dass existenz kein
prädikat ist aber jetzt nimmt er eben
mal das gegenteil an
das ist dann diese reduktion absurdum
wenn existenz ein prädikat ist dann
ergibt es dann gibt es objekte dient das
seien abgesprochen wird
das wäre praktisch ein prädikat ist ein
prädikat eine sache muss das prädikat
nicht haben aber kann das haben also
wenn es ein plagiat ist dann kann es
objekte oder dinge geben die das nicht
haben
es ist ja nicht notwendig habe prädikate
ist nicht notwendig weiter gehts dies
bedeutet aber anders formuliert
folgendes einiges sein de fällt unter
den begriff des nicht sein bzw einiges
sein ist nicht jetzt ist natürlich klar
dass der satz einiges sein das ist nicht
widersprüchlich ist also ist existenz
bzw nichtexistenz kein prädikat der
punkt ist wir müssen ja immer wenn wir
existenz etwas zu sprechen es schon
annehmen als irgendwie existieren
insofern ist es widersinnig dass als ein
prädikat anzusehen das ist so ungefähr
die richtung von pflege und jetzt sagt
rege am schluss ganz interessantes zitat
man sieht hier aus wie leicht man durch
die sprache zu falschen auffassung
verleitet wird und welchen wert ist
daher für die philosophie haben muss
sich der herrschaft der sprache zu
entziehen wenn man versucht auf ganz
anderen grundlagen mit ganz anderen
mitteln ein zeichensystem zu errichten
wie ich es bei der erfindung meine
begriffs schrift versucht habe wird man
auf die falschen analogien in der
sprache sozusagen mit der nase gestoßen
also wir werden durch unsere natürliche
sprache zu falschen auffassung verleitet
wie zum beispiel nachfrage dass existenz
ein prädikat ist und die philosophie die
hat die aufgabe die sprache zu
kritisieren eben durch die analyse und
uns zuvor zu schützen das führt
natürlich zum anderen bekannten
philosophen ludwig wittgenstein der
gesagt hat die philosophie hilft uns
dabei und zu schützen dass unser
verstand nicht von unserer sprache
verhext wird das ist so die sehr
ähnliche darstellung von wittgenstein zu
dieser sache